now to the war in Ukraine and the latest
reports that the conflict has spilled
across the Russian border after a second
day of fighting in Russia's belgarad
region the Russian foreign Ministry says
the militants that it blames for
Monday's attack have been pushed back
into Ukraine Ukraine's government says
it has nothing to do with the fighting
there James landale with our partners at
the BBC has more from Ukraine
well the picture is confused but what
seems to have happened here is the
largest cross-border incursion since
this War Began what we know is that a
group of armed men crossed from
Northeast Ukraine into Russia the
Kremlin calls them Ukrainian saboteurs
the intelligence Department here in Kiev
says no they were Russian paramilitaries
partisans who are opposed to Vladimir
Putin either way these men crossed the
border and attempted to seize two or
three villages there are reports they
had armored vehicles with them and this
morning the local Russian Governor has
said that they even had drones which
aired fences have been shot down
Russia says it's carrying out a
counter-terrorist operation it seems
that the fighting still continues and
there are reports of eight people being
injured now this is potentially
embarrassing to Moscow because it will
allow critics to suggest that it can't
control its own borders and defend them
but equally this is problematic for the
government here in Kiev because it will
allow Russia to claim that Ukraine is
not just defending its own borders but
is potentially a threat to Russia itself
James Landau BBC news for CBS mornings
Ukraine